let's go - where do we want to go next
let's go to the 631 area code caller
from 631 who's this okay yeah yeah who's
this
good afternoon mr. Pakman this is Tim
from for God Millennials how are ya
good how are you I'm doing well I'm
gonna be you know shortened to the point
I wanted to get your stance on the Syria
pull out and if you were in any Rhine
with you know Rachel Maddow and a lot of
other left-wing commentators and wanting
to stay in Syria I couldn't tell you
what other people are saying because
quite frankly I don't really watch
anything so I would be taking your word
as to what the position of others is so
here here's my position on Syria I am
generally speaking against the military
intervention that the United States has
chosen to do in the region for a variety
of different reasons the reasons are
moral the reasons our economic there's a
whole bunch of different reasons that
being said I want to know what the
actual motivations are when we make
decisions to either send or pull troops
out of any particular place both the
timing and motivations of Donald Trump's
decision are suspect and we've seen how
they connect to Jim mattis leaving chief
of staff John Kelly saying he prevented
Trump from doing this for a while we've
seen how this ties in to the Kurds and
Turkey and Saudi Arabia and Putin so I
think that the the only real serious
position to have on Syria is a
multi-faceted one that accounts not only
for what would we like in a vacuum but
that sort of accounts for the political
realities of what's going on as well why
did you agree with Obama's move back to
pull out of you know Afghanistan in the
Middle East back then generally speaking
I did agree with scaling down those Wars
now you can make the argument that once
the circumstances were at a particular
level of progression or at a particular
point in time that in the short term
some of those decisions could be
connected
ooh flare-ups and violence or
deleterious effect but generally
speaking as I've said I am generally
against the interventions that the
United States has done in the region
okay and kind of just going up with what
you said before and I don't mean any
disrespect like this by the way um that
you don't watch anything how do you you
know get your information or gather
information for your show ever you know
where do you look I read I really read
your English sources I mean I've got you
know I'm reading everything from news
reporting from just basic you know
Associated Press wire services to
investigative journalism done by
everybody from the New York Times and
The Washington Post who all sorts of
smaller outlets and then you know I read
the opinion of of several hundred people
who are op-ed people that I follow on
Twitter so I kind of start with wire
services I go to larger media outlets
and then I go to analysts and
commentators okay okay that's a pretty
good dissemination I'll wanted to long
just kind of put my two cents in on it I
think it is a good move that we're
getting a serious I know there was a
vacuum last time that created a larger
Isis I think we beat them down enough
obviously they're not going to be
completely obliterated either way it's
an idea at the end of the day but I
think I think he's assessed the fact
that Democrats are back in you know the
house and he wants to pull out and
possibly get more funding for the wall
if he's gonna get the funding from the
Democrats or if he's gonna get funding
through you know less military action
was military spending you know
allocating that money to national
security on the border I think that kind
of where his motivation is on this yeah
I disagree I don't think there's any
evidence that Trump is even remotely
capable of that type of abstract
thinking of any kind I've seen no
evidence whatsoever I think if we if I
want to find motivations for what Trump
is doing that are beyond what has been
stated publicly their nefarious and they
connect to either quid pro quo or other
reasons but we just disagree there you
know that's and that's fine
we've you think pulling out of a war in
the barrier no no I didn't pull out his
nefarious I said that the underlying
reasons and
motivations may be connected to
nefarious doings and connections to
other countries I've already talked
about how this plays in specifically to
the geopolitics of a number of other
countries I've talked about the
connection to Saudi Arabia and Turkey
related to the Shamal Kichijoji killing
and if so I I've seen no evidence that
trump is capable of the abstract
thinking that you suggested and we've
seen plenty of evidence that donald
trump is able to be manipulated by
foreign powers so i what we have
evidence will be manipulated by foreign
powers what's the evidence for that I
mean it goes all the way back to the
campaign over the summer where the
position of the Republican Party by Paul
Manafort was forced to be changed with
regard to Russia and Ukraine and I mean
I don't know if you've been following
the news for the last couple years but
there's a very long list at this point
yes but everyone it's people around him
just like Hillary Clinton it was people
around her as well as quitting her
organizations so I mean if it's people
in Trump's administration and not Trump
himself Trump hired them and he's the
president so the Bucks got to stop with
him right right I mean what also of all
of Bill Ayers as well I mean we are
we're going to disagree I call that's
where you go Bhama
and what does Obama and Bill Ayers have
to do with whether Donald Trump has been
compromised by a foreign power tell me
specifically the question specifically
and you can answer it don't worry what
does Bill Ayers have to do with
evaluating whether Trump is manipulated
by foreign powers so you're talking
about affiliation with Trump anyone
that's affiliated with Trump in his
administration
where was Bill Ayers someone that Obama
hired who was making policy decisions
for him know that once what about Louis
Farrakhan the anti-semite when he was
under the house meeting with him
multiple times I've denounced Louis
Farrakhan probably two dozen times
nothing you you I'm not saying you I
know you would denounce with Farrakhan
I've seen you do it on yourself but I'm
staying with
Bhama he is affiliated himself in
congressional buildings with this man
has no way to have four residents but it
doesn't have anything to do with whether
Putin or turkey or Assad or whoever is
connected to trump it just has nothing
to do with it so do you think Assad is
going to you know quote unquote gas his
own people while we're trying to pull
out of Syria what does it matter whether
I think that that's what Assad will do
well I just want to get your take on
that because you know I have no idea
when we ride abroad I have no idea when
Assad is gonna gas his own people what
does that have to do with whether Trump
is I'm saying do you think it will
happen I'm saying do you think it would
happen I'm telling you I don't know if
we're trying to pull out I'm telling you
I don't know okay taking a populated by
Putin
I don't think soap is being manipulated
by Putin oh I know I could have some
sort of a yeah but I'm I'm not on Putin
side per se but I'm saying we're going
to have it no I'm saying that we as an
anti-war person someone that doesn't
want war around the world
someone Trump being a person that has
ended the North Korean War
what has taken or peed man would you to
be that ending the war in Korea he is
ending the war in Korea you realize this
entire thing about quote ending the
Korean War is an irrelevant formality
and that Trump has achieved nothing in
North Korea right how is it a relevant
formality that Mike Pompeo went down
there ten other occasions and went to
Kim jong-un and has been negotiating
within this entire time meanwhile the
South Korean president comes out and
praises Trump for making this happen
making the meetings on the DMZ happen
what's been a cut across the DMZ hasn't
happened what's been accomplished in
North Korea the quality of the DMV's
multiple nuclear facilities being taken
out there's new Marvel constantly going
over there they're actually rebuilding
the railways between North and South
Korea I'm not sure if you know this they
are rebuilding them I think when you
jump the shark was when you mentioned
Bill Ayers I would stay away from that
that's
that's gonna rot your brain all right
thank you for the call Tim Tim the
millennial or something like that was
his name okay I'm out of time thank you
to everybody that called and we'll take
more calls next week